un esfuerzo por retomar las relaciones
unos 40 líderes africanos fueron
recibidos en bruselas para la cumbre de
dos días entre los representantes de
ambos continentes uno de los objetivos
es convencerlos de que europa es su
socio más confiable y para ello lanzaron
una iniciativa millonaria we can expect
pudimos esperar un paquete de al menos
150 mil millones de euros para áfrica
durante los próximos 7 años este es el
primer paquete de nuestra estrategia
global gateway el presupuesto que
responde a la mitad de un plan de
300.000 millones de euros que busca
apoyar el desarrollo africano en los
ámbitos de la salud y la educación y al
tiempo contrarrestar la creciente
influencia económica de china y rúsia en
el continente
las tensiones entre áfrica y europa se
han profundizado los flujos migratorios
conflictos que se recrudecen como en el
tigre etíope y la erosión de la
democracia en varios países africanos
algunos de los cuales han sufrido
recientemente golpes de estado
este es la cumbre de un nuevo comienzo
de una asociación renovada espero que
nuestras conversaciones den frutos en
todos los temas principales ya sea la
paz y la seguridad la lucha contra el
terrorismo pero también la financiación
de las economías africanas
uno de los puntos más candentes es el
acceso a las vacunas contra el hobbit 19
en áfrica donde apenas el 11% de la
población está completamente inmunizada
áfrica ha señalado el viejo continente
de acaparar tanto vacunas como equipos
de protección dejando al descubierto una
inmensa brecha en una relación que se
plantea supuestamente como una entre
iguales uno de los objetivos del bloque
europeo es establecer la agencia
africana de medicamentos con la que el
continente podría producir el 60 por
ciento de las vacunas que necesita para
el 2040